- The Stream for those of y'all
who have not been here before.
This is a way for us all to stay connected
as you have now school
closures around the world.
Khan Academy, we're a not
for profit with the mission
of providing a free world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And the way we've been
doing that for years
is by making resources
from as early as pre-K,
Khan Academy Kids that
goes through Kindergarten
and first grade, and then
resources in Math, English,
Language Arts, Science, Humanities,
all the way through elementary, middle,
high school, and even the
foundations of college.
That's always been there,
but when the school closures
started happening a few weeks ago,
we realized it's our duty to do more.
So we've been doing parent webinars,
and teacher webinars
with daily live stream
to stay connected.
And we've been publishing
things like schedules
for students of different age groups.
And over the course of the
next few hours, actually,
we're gonna be publishing some
learning plans for students
at different grade levels,
for how you can learn through
the end of the school year,
and keep learning, ideally,
through the summer.
I do wanna remind folks,
we are a not for profit.
And we're funding by
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I do wanna give a quick shout out
to several corporations
who've stepped up in the last few weeks
when they saw that our.
Folks like Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, and Novartis.
And I wanna thank our
many other supporters.
But even with that, we
were running at a deficit
before the crisis hit.
And the costs have gone even higher.
But with that, I'd like to
introduce our guest for today.
David Coleman from the College Board,
CEO of the College Board,
another not for profit
that we have been close
partners with for many years
around official SAT practice.
And David, maybe a good place to start,
even before our live stream started,
and I encourage everyone to ask questions
on the message boards.
We have team members looking at it.
But we had a lot of
questions about AP exams,
and how that's all going to work out.
So I'd love to hear how you
all are thinking about it,
and how it's going to
play out for students.
Thanks, Sal.
And I hope you and your family is well,
and your colleagues are well
through this demanding time.
I know people are working at home
and facing the demands of,
sometimes, their children
and other forces.
And not to be somber,
but I know this can be,
has already been for some
and will be for others,
a time of loss.
And I just wanna offer
our heartfelt condolences
and support for people who
are struggling through this.
And I know it sounds
weird to begin this way,
but there are definitely things
more important in this life
than AP and SAT.
And those include the safety
and sanctity of everyone.
And I know you and I
are also very concerned
that this crisis will hit the low income
and under-represented communities hardest
in this country as things
like this always do.
And that's why Khan
Academy is such a beacon,
available on any device to any person.
What an equalizer.
And I'll talk a little bit
of why the digital divide
can still make that hard,
but I don't know of a force
that is as astonishing as Khan Academy is
in offering such a high
quality to everyone.
When we partnered with Khan Academy,
it was not to provide free test prep, Sal,
as you said.
It was to provide the best test prep
that happened to be free.
And Khan Academy has delivered on that.
The quality of your team's
work in everything it touches
continues to amaze me and inspire me
and us at the College Board.
And my most important
message today, maybe,
never has the importance of Khan Academy
been more evident to the world.
And I just hope people listening to this
really understand that donating to one
of the great public utilities of our time,
on of the great public goods of our time,
which is Khan Academy,
is urgent and important.
It's now evident that it is
essential to everyone alive.
And let's help make it
so by investing in it.
Know that we invest in
you due to your great work
in the SAT with us,
and we work with a lot of players
in this space and we regard
none higher than Khan Academy
in the quality of its work and its ethos.
So sorry for that long preamble,
but I think that's really important.
- No, I appreciate that, David.
And how are you doing?
I mean, it's my bad
for, you're in New York,
I know your partner and--
- I'm really well.
My husband is an ICU nurse,
so I'm super proud of him.
He's on the front lines every day
and I'm trying to do my
best to keep them safe
and help them along.
And we have young twins that are five,
that are irreverent as ever.
And they're thriving.
I cannot complain of my
individual circumstances.
And I get to talk about,
as many people have,
my concerns about my
parents and various places
and all of that.
But all together, Sal, we're well.
And we at the College Board are energized
by what we're attempting to do.
We've chosen to come at this crisis
with a spirit of
innovation and flexibility.
And so let me outline
what we're doing about AP,
because I know people
have a lot of questions.
I'm gonna apologize, I'll
read a couple of things here,
because I wanna get the
facts exactly right,
and then turn to your questions.
I hope I've made clear
that the health and safety
of educators, families, is
the most important thing
driving the College Board.
And of course students at this time.
That is our top priority.
So as students and families
and teachers navigate these challenges,
we've done two pivotal things.
First we have launched AP
Live to provide every student,
in a regular schedule each
day, free online review
and coursework around every AP course.
And as of now there have
been 4.7 million views
of that content.
And number two, we're providing
all students the chance
to test safely at home this spring.
And I'll outline that
assessment opportunity.
And to be clear, before
we made that decision,
which was a hard decision
because it forces
an enormous amount of work and innovation
on the College Board's part
to design an at-home exam.
But we found when we
surveyed 18,000 students,
that over 91% of them said
they wanted the opportunity
to take an exam and claim
the credit we've earned.
Let's remember, the crisis hit after 75%
of the school year was
done, so these are students
who've been working all
year in their AP classrooms.
So we felt that we could make
only one principle decision,
that we would provide
a brief, at-home exam
to allow students to show
what they've learned.
And that exam could only cover information
in that first 75% of the course.
Units that are typically covered,
so we will not include the material
that is typically covered
in March and April
when schools were out of session.
If you wanna learn more
about either AP Live
or the exams, you can
always go to CB.org/AP.
Let me tell you a little
bit more about the solution.
It will be a 45 minute online exam at home
for this year and this year alone.
Educator-led development communities,
which are a blend of
higher education professors
and high school AP teachers,
are currently selecting the exam questions
that will be administered.
Exams will be given May 11th through 15th,
and May 18th to 22nd.
And make up test dates will be available
for each subject from June 1st to 5th,
but I strongly encourage all students
to take the exam in that
original testing window
when we're more assured
of our full capacity
to reach every student.
And as I mentioned before, we recognize
that the digital divide could prevent
some low income and rural
students from participating.
Working with partners,
we're heavily investing
so that these students have
the tools and connectivity
and technical support they need
to review AP content online
and take the exam.
If you are a student who needs help
or you're a teacher whose
students need mobile tools
or connectivity, you can
reach out to us directly
to let us know by April 24th.
Please complete the form at CB.org/tech,
CB.org/tech.
And I'm really proud
that 50 of my colleagues
have given of their time
to reach out directly
to these families and
students to make sure
that we complete the last mile.
And understand the pressures
on homeless students
and other students in our society
that may be without devices or bandwidth,
or in homes where bandwidth is scarce
and devices are shared.
We'll continue to support
students with free resources
through exam day, and
while we encourage students
to wait till closer to
the test date to decide,
any student now registered
for exam can choose to cancel
at no charge.
And I have good news, we're
confident that the vast majority
of higher education institutions
will honor the credit
from these courses.
We've gotten an overwhelming response.
The University of California
just published a statement,
I believe it's now up to 22
states that have endorsed
this solution, and several
private institutions
and more are coming in every day.
So there's enormous consensus in higher ed
to honor the work done on these exams,
and give credit and placement accordingly.
So for seniors it will
offer credit and placement
for their futures if they succeed,
and for juniors it will offer all of that
and also distinguish themselves
on the way to college.
And at a time when family's
incomes are compromised
across this country,
we felt it was our obligation, Sal,
to press on innovation in
order to make sure kids
didn't lose their chance
to earn the credit
that they had done.
I could say a little bit
more later if you'd like
about the AP Live sessions,
and I've told you you
can go to the website
and look at it.
I just wanna be clear though,
that nothing that happens in AP Live,
as cool as I think it is,
will be required on the exam.
We know some kids will not have access
to future online learning,
so the exams only cover
what you've already done
in the first 75% of the course.
We'll be adding optional
student practice online
for students to practice for free.
And again, let me say a little
bit more now about the exams.
They're for this year only.
We'll go back to our traditional AP exams.
These streamlined exams
will not require any textbook shipments,
external proctors or
any additional workload.
Again, the exam content will
only cover topics and skills
most AP teachers and
students have already covered
in class by March.
And students will be able to
take these streamlined exams
on any device they have access to.
A computer, a tablet, or smartphone,
they can even take a
picture on a smartphone
of their hand written
work and upload that.
Most exams will be given
from May 11th to the 22nd.
And as I said, the make up
dates will be June 1st to 5th.
In the unlikely event that schools reopen,
students can take these exams there.
Let me say a little bit
more about the exam format.
Most exams will have one or
two free response questions,
and each question will
be timed separately.
So students will need to write
and submit their responses
within the allotted
time for each question.
For most subjects, the exam
will be 45 minutes long,
plus an additional five
minutes for uploading.
Students will need to access
the online testing system
30 minutes early to get set up.
Certain courses, such
as AP Art and Design 2D,
Art and Design 3D, Computer
Science Principals,
Drawing, Research, and Seminar
will use portfolios submission
and it will not have a
separate online exam.
All deadlines for these
submissions have been extended
to May 26th at 11:59 pm
for those who cut it close,
Eastern time.
Teachers and students
will receive special
course-specific communications
on these projects.
And interestingly and excitingly,
students taking World Language
and Culture exams will complete
solely two spoken tasks,
consistent with free response
questions three and four
in the current AP exam.
They'll be given an oral
exam by a qualified adult.
And so we're really going
direct from readers to students
to hear their command of the language.
As you can see, what we've
tried to do is we've tried
to make the exams much simpler, briefer.
I want students to feel
confident that they've got this.
They've done the work the first
three quarters of the exam,
we're not trying to trick you,
we're not trying to surprise you,
we're actually trying
to just give you a venue
to show you what you know.
I've never been more confident
the majority of students
should be able to flourish on these exams.
And if you want, Sal,
I'll end with a few words
on security, because I must.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Because of course people wonder,
how can we give these
exams securely at home?
Like many college level exams,
they'll be open book and open note.
The exam format and questions
are being designed specifically
for an at-home administration,
so points won't be given to you
for things you could find out
from Google or elsewhere online.
However, now I must be more than clear,
students may not consult
with any other individuals
during the testing period.
And we'll take the necessary
steps to protect the integrity
of the exam administration.
And, you know, I say this,
I'm confident that the vast
majority of AP students
will follow the rules
for taking the exams.
And there's something kind
of crazy about cheating
on the AP exam, because
who wants to wind up
in Advanced Calculus
that's not ready for it?
But we will nonetheless
put in strict measures
to avoid cheating, including
plagiarism software,
and several other efforts.
I don't wanna go into them too much depth,
because the more I talk about them,
they're not as strong a security measures.
But they are strong.
And they surround the
student in various ways.
And they are taking
serious the possibility
of students having someone
else impersonate themselves
and show their work,
or going to the internet to
share with other students
or conference calls with other students.
We've thought of all the scenarios
and put tactics in place.
But I need to warn students
in this special circumstance,
the College Board will
be tougher on cheating.
Students who are found cheating
in this kind of situation,
we will not only, as usual,
merely cancel your score,
we're gonna let every university know
that you've sent an SAT score,
if we have conclusive evidence,
that you've sent an SAT
score or other AP scores too,
that you were found cheating
in this environment.
So it would be a foolish move
that would limit one's further
to cheat in this environment.
But that said, putting
that dark specter aside,
I think this is an
extraordinary opportunity
for AP students.
There's free live lessons every day,
brief exams that will reinforce,
that will reflect your mastery.
And I really look forward
to see what kids can do,
and student can do.
That's it, Sal,
thanks for your time.
- No, that' super helpful.
And I think it already
addresses a lot of the questions
that we've been getting.
A few things you've mentioned, though,
I think are interesting
and address some questions.
I think we can highlight, from Instagram,
@earthly1008 asked,
I've only a mobile phone
and I took AP Calc BC, so
will it be possible for me
to take the exam?
It sounds like it will?
- It will, it will.
The only disadvantage of a mobile phone
is typically in the humanities,
when some of the prompts
may be a little longer.
It'll be a little annoying
to scroll through them
on your phone.
But that doesn't mean that you can either
then type back your answers
on the mobile phone,
or in the BC Calculus situation,
that person could write their work,
take a picture of it and
upload it in the phone.
But then they can get all
the prompts from the phone,
they can get the questions
from the phone, yep.
- And what about students
who don't even have that,
or they may be afraid that
their phone isn't good enough?
You mentioned CB.org/tech?
How would that work?
- That's exactly right.
The way it's working,
Sal, it's really exciting.
When we made the announcement,
we gave that address
to every student.
And 2000 thus have
gotten in touch with us,
and we're getting back to them.
We have thousands of Chromebooks
that we're trying to make
sure those Chromebooks get
to just those students who need them most,
who really can't borrow a
device or need them on test day.
So we're trying to really ask people
to be restrained in what they ask for.
We're gonna loan them out
and ask for them back.
We are working with other
state and district partners
to ensure that their device strategies
are coordinated and they're
getting to these AP students
who need them.
A lot of this, Sal, as you
know is case management.
And we're investing today
in providing wide-reaching tech support.
Because sometimes it's
actually tech support
that gets in the way.
But if you have a concern,
please go to CB.org/tech.
- That's super helpful.
I have a question from YouTube,
Dara Rayblott is asking,
will there be practice
tests, example questions
in the same style as the
new at-home questions?
- Yes there will.
And some of them are gonna roll
out by the end of the week,
and then we will be having
more practice for you.
We may even have, we're just designing now
ways that you can simulate
the test experience
and test the systems.
And a way you can further take
practice questions as you go.
So the answer is yes, already
by the end of the week
there'll be practice, and
there'll be more to come
as we further develop it.
- And there's two questions
here that are related.
One is from, they're both from YouTube.
IshaKonham is asking,
will the AP exam be harder
to compensate for open notes?
And Lucy is asking, how is
the AP curve going to work
for students if the tests
are going to be open notes?
- Well, the curve is not really affected,
because you're still evaluating students
on a one through five scale
as to whether their work
represents college-ready work
in a more-or-less advance level.
And we're still gonna have the
distributed reading process.
So readers won't meet in person,
but we'll still have college
faculty and AP teachers
reading the work and
making those judgments.
I think students should
enter this exam situation
with great confidence.
I wanna be clear that if
you look at what's happening
in higher ed, and what's
happening in the AP program,
we're trying to get every
chance to students today.
We know that students
are under very stressful circumstances,
and so we're trying to make
the exam as brief as possible.
We don't wanna surprise anyone,
we wanna make the questions,
as much as possible,
look like work already done in the class
so that we can look at
that value-added analysis,
you can do the synthesis,
you can do the analysis,
you do not just regurgitate facts.
But we're not trying
to trick you in any way
and it should be very
routine with the kind of work
you've already been
doing in the classroom.
- And there's another
question here on technology
from Facebook, alpanaloyelka asks,
we have internet issues from time to time,
what would be a good backup
that you would suggest
in case it happens in
the middle of the exam?
- I think then the make up testing
is gonna be essential, Sal.
So what I would like people to do,
is what we're not finding
so far in our testing.
I know people worry about like
the earth shattering moment
the internet goes down
just at the very moment they're testing.
But what's more likely is people
haven't checked their browsers,
and haven't gone through
the exam simulation process
and have a tech support
issue they didn't expect.
So we will ask students
to go through simulations
in advance, and I'm kind
of as much as possible
asking all students to really do that,
and we will monitor that closely.
And second of all, as I said,
please sign up 30 minutes
before the exam begins.
- That's useful.
And there's a lot of questions,
for those of you all who don't know,
the College Board, which
you all are not for profit
that represents essentially
a board of colleges.
You represent what the
colleges are thinking
on a lot of levels.
And you all are also, as
we talked about earlier,
the administer of the SAT.
And we're close partners on that
around official SAT practice.
Couple of questions on that front,
but related to this notion
of potential at-home testing.
From YouTube, Tom Bert is asking,
is the College Board preparing
for home online SAT testing
in the eventuality COVID-19 prevents
using testing centers in June?
- I think the eventuality
in which the College Board
is preparing for, and
that I've talked about
in a previous communication.
So our members, Sal, just to be clear,
are virtually all the
nation's high schools
and all the colleges.
And so we work together with high schools
and colleges to make that connection.
Not only domestically, but globally.
And the SAT's part of that.
But my brief answer to the question is,
I think we will need an
at-home style solution
for the SAT if schools are out this fall,
and we'll be giving more updates
on our progress towards
that in about a week's time.
But we have announced
that we are preparing
in that sad eventuality,
that our society really is off-kilter
and kids can't get back
into a school setting
by this fall, that we
will develop alternatives.
- Yep.
And there's one thing
that I think you said
two questions ago that I
really wanna highlight.
When people are asking
about the curve of AP.
It's really important
for people to recognize,
if everyone who takes the
AP exam knows the material
at a five level, you will
give everyone a five.
I not one does, you'll all get ones.
- Once again showing that
you are better at this
than I am sometimes, no, kidding.
Kidding aside, it's a
perfect thing Sal says,
there is no curve in that sense.
It's not like there's only
so many fives to give out,
so many fours, so many threes.
We are really trying to create a situation
where students who have
done the work of this class
can with confidence do well on this exam.
- And there's a lot of questions--
Oh, go ahead.
- I just wanna be clear
about something.
Oh, sorry Sal.
We know that like while it's
cool that we have AP Live,
that a lot of students have
other things going on right now.
And they might just have
the time to take the exam.
And we've really designed
this exam to make sure
that even if you don't
have a bunch of time
to do a lot of studying
in between now and then,
you still should be able to show your work
and do well.
So we've tried to be very attentive
to the mix of circumstances our
students find themselves in.
- And we've gotten a ton of questions,
not just today, but in
previous live streams
around, I think it's
mainly high school juniors,
who are just stressed a little bit
about the college application
process generally,
and given all of the volatility.
They might not have, I know
some of the local districts
have gone pass/fail for this term.
Y'all represent these colleges
and all things admissions,
and things like that.
What are you hearing from them?
- Yeah, I'm gonna do my best to give you
as straight a shot as I can, Sal.
I would urge immense calm
on the part of students
for a certain reason.
Colleges want them more than ever.
Colleges are concerned
about filling their classes,
about students coming back.
So don't think it hasn't
affected everyone.
So colleges are hungrier
than ever for talent,
are hungrier than ever to find students.
They're worried about recruiting students,
they're worried about students
from various communities
not being adequately represented
on their college campuses.
So it's never been a better time
to be a student applying to college.
There's such a hunger
among the nation's colleges
to re-engage with you, get
back in touch with you,
and develop your plans with you.
Don't sweat the small stuff.
A pass/fail grade, or taking
the SAT later in the year
than you expected.
You know, claim your opportunity
with AP, get it done.
But this is a time where everyone
realizes what's important.
And all I would tell you,
is if there's a blessing
at a time like this,
from what I know about college admissions,
is high school students,
many of them could do with
being a lot less busy, Sal.
Sometimes applying to
colleges becomes this frenzy
of doing tons of activities,
and trying to distinguish
yourself every which way.
And the truth of college admissions
is doing very well at your school work
and doing one thing
outside of it that you love
and show your strength
in, is really enough.
And I hope that as we realize this,
this crisis makes clear, that
real love for a few things
matters more than being
busy and time with family.
And I hope that we come back
to a more balanced approach
as we return to schooling this fall.
- And that's a good segue, David.
Now I want to give you a chance,
and I applaud what you and
the entire College Board team
is doing, I can't imagine
all of the complexities
you're trying to navigate right now,
in record time.
But I always, for those of
you all who don't realize,
David and I are actually
quite good friends,
over the course of many years,
we've had many late night conversations
where I'm trying to
expand David's imagination
in one direction or another. (laughs)
And he's doing the same.
- No charge for the call, for the record.
- (laughs) No, maybe we'll get into it.
But what I always tell people,
even when we first partnered
with the College Board,
and people are like,
"Oh, the College Board,
"that's that big institution
that administers these tests,"
and all this.
I was like, you gotta meet David,
he's not what you're imagining as the CEO,
the president of the College Board.
And frankly, everyone
at the College Board,
are these really thoughtful
people who are really out there
that just do right by you the students,
and the teachers, and the parents.
And so David, and I always admired you
for your ability to
think broadly about life
and where we sit and the
history and things like that.
What advice do you have for
everyone going through this
as people, but especially
as students right now?
- Many people will say to you
that everything is changed.
And so I wanna start by
what remains the same.
The most powerful thing
you can do as a student
is to develop authentic fascinations.
And what I hope AP is for students
is a chance to gain the
pleasure and challenge
of getting really good at something.
And I know that sounds super simple,
but I want you to think for a moment
about this one precious
life you've been given.
And how meaningful it is to
get fascinated by something,
to fall into something.
And when you think about
applying to college,
if you think, boy, what
does it really take?
It takes getting to know
your teachers really well
and finding some great teachers.
Because those mentors
are everything to us.
It means falling in love
with your academic work,
to some degree, but particularly
certain parts of it.
And then it's finding an
activity outside of school
that you devote yourself to.
And what's funny, Sal,
is before the crisis,
we have research on success at college
that says if you do those
things when you get to college,
you're gonna have a great experience.
If you find great teachers,
if you find a class
or discipline that you love
and apply to your life,
and if you love an
activity outside of class.
So, I know that sounds strange,
but it seems to me that
success remains as simple
as kind of falling in love three times.
You know, being devoted to your teachers
and the relationships you have with them.
To disciplines and finding academic work
that really makes you awake at night
and excites you.
And finally, finding an
activity that engages you.
And when Sal and I look at each other
and care for one another, it's in part
because we both love what we do.
Sal is a man energized
entirely by passion.
He began Khan Academy
sharing his delight in math
with his nephew and nieces.
It began as an act of love,
and as kind of irrepressible desire
to bring other people
into the beauty and power
that he found in mathematics.
Sal's passion for that changed the world.
And that cultivation of
passion in excellence
is such a winning hand.
Faking it, being inauthentic,
putting a face on yourself
for college applications,
getting caught up
and doing too many things,
wastes the precious life
we've been given.
But working hard to
discover what you love,
finding teacher that really move you,
these are lasting things.
And what you'll find is later in life,
you know, Sal says he's
impressed with the responsiveness
of the College Board, and
honestly I kind of am too.
A lot of people have canceled exams,
and we came to this with
a very innovative can-do.
We're gonna make it work at home attitude.
But that's in part
because we've been working
with Khan Academy for years.
And we've seen their
agility, and they inspire us.
And so I think that we may be
more distant from one another
for a period of time,
but what really matters
remains strangely the same.
And never has your own motivation,
your own inner drive been
more important than now.
Out of the presence of your teachers,
out of the immediate pressures
of applying to college,
can you cultivate that internal flame
that really is what delivers
you most things of value
in this life.
So that's my pompous
preaching for the day, Sal.
I'm done.
- I think that's gonna
leave a lot of students,
and some of us adults, inspired.
And I think it's exactly right.
I think the first few weeks
of this social distancing,
all of us were fixated on a
thing that we were losing.
But now I think, and I know some people
are in very hard situations,
and everyone is going through
a lot of anxiety and stress,
but we're starting to realize
that there's some silver linings:
more time with family, a lot
of the noise of every day life
has gone away, and we can reflect more.
More times with ourselves to think about
what makes us tick, who are we really?
And I think for high school
students, especially,
the normal world is, there's
just so much going on
in their life.
They don't have the time to reflect.
And this generation,
all of y'all out there,
actually there might be a silver lining
where you have an opportunity
to do what David mentioned.
You have the time to reflect who you are,
what really energizes you,
and be your authentic self
as you apply for college.
So thanks David for joining us.
I hope we can have him on again.
We got a lot of questions today,
more so than normal so
I know there's a lot
of high school students
out there thinking a lot
about college admissions
and APs and SATs.
I always applaud David for his ability
to really speak to the
heart, as you just saw.
Thanks everyone for joining.
As I said, this is a way for
all of us to stay connected.
Not just for y'all to stay connected,
but I also get a lot of personal joy
that I'm also also socially distanced,
to be able to connect with all of y'all.
And as a reminder, we are not for profit,
if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy
so that we can continue to
support the world, hopefully,
in this time of crisis, and beyond.
Have a good day.